Ashi Parmentier's cellular structure can be broadly divided into 3 parts:
meat sauce that gives the minced meat a nice brown color,
creamy mashed potatoes called foam puree,
and cheese.
I wonder what they're asking me to do I wonder if they're going to make a dessert?
I
'm so freaked out
Ahhh Twisted jako I like
the smell of small fish's tide, but I don't know what I can do at all There's no way
I can make a decent dish like this I
can't understand what you're thinking at all I
really noticed  Remember what you touched with the vanishing
extreme power?
The business trip is
trying to create something that can't be
achieved by pre-established harmony by colliding with each other on the web.  Hey, let's get on
everyone's
[music]
ana Are you such a good doctor?
It
's
only
now that I've finally started cooking It's the real meaning Maybe it's finally started now
The kono [music] for her is up to that
point
Sudo style